madureira cuna de la cultura negra en
río de janeiro un barrio popular en el
corazón de la zona norte tal como gran
parte de la comunidad congolesa es aquí
donde vivía muy ezkaba gamble 24 años a
finales de enero el joven fue
brutalmente asesinado golpeado por tres
hombres tras una pelea frente a la
tienda de playa en la que trabajaba
desde aquel día daniel el primo de moix
lucha con su familia para obtener
justicia tras recibir amenazas ahora
viven encerrados y
ya no puedo hacer nada me da miedo lo
que pueda suceder me afuera
yo siento que si salgo puedo ser
asesinado como mi hermano el mismo
ivonne orgullo de la guerra civil en
congo y creía sentirse segura en brasil
donde el 56 por ciento de la población
es afrodescendiente
me dije voy a sentirme libre porque hay
negros mestizos blancos voy a estar bien
efe
pero sucedió lo contrario según el más
reciente mapa de las violencias en el
2019 en brasil el 77% de las víctimas de
homicidios eran negras aquí según daniel
los negros de origen africano sufren una
doble pena
hay una discriminación no solo contra
los negros sino también contra los
extranjeros
he trabajado en varias empresas a veces
para ellos un extranjero es alguien
inferior
y atención
hay cosas a las que no puedes tener
acceso
en señal de protesta ese día en la playa
de vara de yuca barrio privilegiado de
río de janeiro miles de manifestantes se
reunieron en el lugar del crimen frente
a la tienda en la que muestra bajaba
el asunto muy mediatizado reunió a mucha
más gente de la que la familia de moi se
esperaba
más allá del crimen xenófobo los
manifestantes vinieron a denunciar el
racismo estructural de la sociedad
brasileña
hoy estamos reunidos porque aquellos que
asesinan una moix nos asesinan todos los
días de distintas formas el racismo a la
brasilera la xenofobia a
los fascistas en el poder vamos a tumbar
los estamos aquí para gritar las vidas
mientras cuentan y paren de matarnos
crímenes denunciados con frecuencia aquí
en el consejo de la judicatura de río
rodrigo montego defiende a la familia de
maurice y muchos otros los expedientes
se acumulan en su oficina
porque aquí llega un caso y luego otro y
todos son urgentes ningún expediente es
sencillo
lo que este abogado expone es un racismo
que sigue estructurando el orden social
a pesar de las leyes que lo condenan el
país marcado por la esclavitud
reivindicaba desde hace decenios recibir
con los brazos abiertos a todas las
nacionalidades y respetar todos los
colores de piel un mito desmentido todos
los días por rodrigo y sus colegas
y
el estadio prioriza algunos crímenes los
que son cometidos contra personas
blancas son tratados con mucha seriedad
si son cometidos contra personas negras
las investigaciones son mucho más lentas
casi todos los jueces de brasil son
blancos y provienen casi todos de
familias ricas analizando un asunto
sienten más empatía por quien se les
parece que por una persona que es
diferente
injusticias que se repiten casi al mismo
tiempo otro crimen racista enluta rió
mientras regresaba a casa durval teófilo
padre de familia de 38 años fue
asesinado con tres disparos por su
vecino un militar blanco quien dice
haber creído que era un ladrón
un homicidio calificado inicialmente
como involuntario una decisión que
generó escándalo antes de que el
carácter intencional haya sido agregado
a los cargos
a cada entidad
aquí
la estaba
una historia muy común en un país en el
que el racismo estructural sigue dejando
víctimas tan solo en río en estos
últimos 35 años menos de 300 procesos
por injuria y crimen racista se han
traducido en condenas
[Música]